قال وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان انه اكد لنظيره الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان حرص المملكه على تفعيل
الاتفاقيات السابقه بين البلدين لا سيما
الامنيه من جهتها قال عبد الله الذي يزور
الرياض للمره الاولى منذ عوده العلاقات
بين البلدين ان محادثاته مع نظيره السعودي
كانت بناء وان العلاقات مع الرياض في
الاتجاه الصحيح
[موسيقى]
الى تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه بين بلدينا
ياتي لقائنا اليوم استمرارا للخطوات
المتخذه تجاه تنفيذ اتفاق استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وما يمثله من محطه
مفصليه في تاريخ البلدين ومسار الامن
الاقليمي وتاكيدا على الرغبه الصادقه
وجديه الطرفين في التنفيذ بنود الاتفاق
التي تعود بالنفع على البلدين وشعبيهما من
خلال تعزيز الثقه المتبادله توسيع نطاق
التعاون وتعزيز الاستقرار الاقليمي
وزير الخارجات الايرانيه اكد في زيارته
للسعوديه التي تستمر يوما واحدا عزم
البلدين على تعميق العلاقات في مختلف
المجالات واشدد على ان بامكانهم العمل على
حل كافه الموضوعات الاقليميه العالقه
على ضروره الحفاظ على الامن الداخلي
والامن الذاتي المنشا في المنطقه نعتقد ان
فكره تحقيق الامن والتنميه في المنطقه هي
فكره لا يمكن تجزئتها ويمكن لجميع
الفاعلين الاقليميين ان يلعبوا دورا في
هذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع معنا من طهران محمد
مهدي شريعه مداري الباحث المتخصص في
الدراسات السياسيه الاقليميه ومن الرياض
سعد بن عمر مدير مركز القرن العربي
للدراسات ابدا معك سيد سعد سيد سعد وزير
الخارجيات الايرانيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعد زياره قام بها نظيره السعودي
كيف تقرا هذه الزيارات ووتيره هذه
الزيارات
نعم مساء الخير لك ولجمهورك حقيقه يعني
وصول وزير الخارجيه الايراني الى الرياض
اليوم اعتقد انه بناء على برنامج زمني وضع
سلفا في اعاده العلاقه في متعلق
بالاتفاقيه السعوديه الايرانيه الموقعه في
10 مارس وكذلك
التزاما من الطرفين بهذه الاتفاقيه وصولا
لوزير الخارجيه اليوم معها السفير المعين
الايراني في الرياض
يعني هي نتيجه لوصول الاطراف السعوديه
والايرانيه الى قناعه كبيره في مساله
تحقيق ما اتفق عليه سلفا لذلك نجد ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران تحاول ان
الوفاء بالتزاماتهما حسب الجدول الزمني
المرفق بالاتفاقيه مقابل الطرفين يعني
تحقيق التواصل وفقا لما تم الاتفاق عليه
محمد مهدي سيد محمد مه دي تتواصل هذه
الزيارات وتيره هذه الزيارات الى ماذا
تؤشر بتقديرك
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفك السعودي والي جمهور المشاهدين
انا اتصور ان البلدين لهما اراده سياسيه
كامله
لاستئناف العلاقات لتجاوز المشاكل التي
حصلت في الماضي ولاقامه علاقات تعاون
وتكامل بين البلدين من دون شك
تحسين العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه وايضا
مع الدول الاخرى سيترك اثاره على
مجمل العلاقات الاقليميه لكن علينا ان
نعرف جيدا ان البلدين يهتمان في هذه
الفتره لاستئنافي العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
كما ان
الاتفاقيه التي ابرمت بين البلدين في
الصين
قد استثنت او لم تتطرق الى الملفات الاخرى
التي تطرح احيانا والتي يكون لايران او
السعوديه دورا فيها لن تتطرق الى الملفات
الاخرى ما المقصود بذلك اي ملفات
لا لانه ورد في التقرير ان اولا وزير
الخارجيه الايراني اليوم تحدث عن منظومه
الامن الاقليمي ويقصد بالتحديد منظومه
الامن في الخليج الفارسي واراد ان يؤكد
ضروره ان تكون منظومه الامن منظومه ذاتيه
لكن في التقرير ورد تاثير العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه في سائر الملفات في
المنطقه
مختلف الملفات الموجود في الحقيقه الاتفاق
الايراني السعودي لم يتطرق الى هذه
الملفات المملكه العربيه السعوديه خلال
مفاوضاتها مع الجانب الايراني في فتره
مكان حينما كانت هذه المفاوضات في العراق
او بعد ذلك في عمان كانت تصير على
وضع حل
للازمه الجاريه في اليمن وايران كان
موقفها دائما ان
اليمن وموضوع يمني يمني ويمني سعودي ولا
علاقه للجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه في كل ذلك ولذلك رفضت ان يدخل
موضوع الملف اليمني في المفاوضات واصرت
على استئناف العلاقات الثنائيه وبعد ذلك
يمكن الحديث عن الامور الاخرى يعني سنعود
الى هذه القضايا بالتفصيل اسمع منك سيد
سعد بتقديرك ما هي الملفات التي تم طرحها
في هذه اللقاءات وخاصه اللقاء الاخير بين
وزير الخارجيات الايراني ونظيره السعودي
نعم اعتقد ان هناك
اتفاقات حصلت بين المملكه وايران كانت
واضحه وقع عليها الطرفان تشمل قضايا
المنطقه المختلف عليها والصراعات
الهيدروجيه التي تشكو منها السعوديه
والدول العربيه في المنطقه والزام ايران
في احد البنود الاتفاقيه بعدم التدخل في
الشان العربي مساله السيد لم يطلع على هذه
الاتفاقيه طبعا هذا شيء يعود له لكن لم
لم يوقع الطرفان على الاتفاقيه الا بعد
وضوح كل شيء
لها يعني
تخفيض التصعيد في المنطقه سواء على مستوى
الحشد الشعبي في العراق او اليمن او لبنان
او حتى سوريا لذلك الاتفاقيه السعوديه
الايرانيه هي الان تمشي يعني توازنا مع ما
اتفق فيه التنفيذيا ويكفي اننا اليوم وصل
وزير الخارجيه الى الرياض وهناك وفد عماني
توجه الى صنعاء لمناقشه مساله السلام
والبحث في السلام ايران لها دور لا شك لا
نستطيع ان ننكر في مساله اليمن وايضا
الاتفاق هذا يشمل يعني
اتفاقات واضحه
للدول المنطقه وخفض التصعيد سواء على
مستوى اليمن او على مستوى اي دوله اخرى
ايضا هناك لا ننسى ان السعوديه يعني تركز
على عامل رئيسي اللي هو الامن الاستراتيجي
في المنطقه
وكف اذرع ايران عن التطور في مساله اغلاق
الامن العربي بصفه عامه بينما ايرانت تركز
على مساله عوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
والاقتصاديه وهذا اهم ما يهم ايران وهذا
من شانهم ومن حقهم ايضا لكن بالنسبه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لا تعطي
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه
ادبلوماسيه اهميه بمثل ما تعطي مساله
امتثال ايران لما اتفق عليه في بكي سيد
محمد مهدي ما رايك
طبعا انا احترم
ضيفك ورايه
على الرغم من ان لهجته لا تتلائم مع
الموقف السعودي الحالي في موضوع الملفات
الاقليميه والقضايا الاخرى التي تحدث عنها
ضيفك انها وردت في الاتفاقيه الكل يعلم ما
ورد في هذه الاتفاقيه وانا احيل الموضوع
ليس الى الجانب الايراني بل الى تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه السعودي ومنها التصريحات
التي ادلى بها اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي
المشترك مع نظيره الايراني لم يتطرق الا
الى موضوع الامن في منطقه الخليج الفارسي
والعلاقات الامنيه السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
والامنيه بين الطرفين اما في موضوع ما
اشار اليه ضيفك الكريم في عدم التدخل هذا
مبدا عام لم يكن بشكل الذي اشار اليه
وانما هناك مبدا عام وهو التزام جميع
الدول بعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول الاخرى وهذا عاده يرد في الكثير من
الوثائق السياسيه والاتفاقيات التي تبرم
بين الدول وليست هناك اشاره الى اي من
الطرفين لا الى ايران ولا السعوديه ولا
الى الملفات التي ذكرها مطلقا
وانما بشكل عام اشاره الى هذا المبدا
ويشمل هذا المبدا كلا الطرفين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه سيد سعد هذه الزيارات لن تؤدي
عفوا سيد مهدي يعني هذه الزيارات الن تؤدي
الى دفع التفاهم على قضايا عالقه بين
الجانبين
من دون شك من دون شك اي تقدم في تحسين
العلاقات الثنائيه والاقليميه يؤدي ويؤثر
على مختلف القضايا العالقه بين هذه بين
الطرفين او بين الاطراف في المنطقه لكن هل
يعني هذا اولا الجانب السعودي اكد على
النقطه الامنيه الجانب الايراني ايضا اكد
على العلاقات السياسيه وعلى تنفيذ وكلاهما
اكد على تنفيذ الاتفاقيات السابقه هناك
اتفاقيه امنيه مشتركه هناك اتفاقيه تعاون
اقتصادي
ومواضيع هذه الاتفاقيات واضحه لدى الجميع
لكن من دون شك اي تقارب في المنطقه سيترك
اثارا ايجابيه على مختلف الملفات في هذه
المنطقه طيب سيدي سعد بن عمر وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه قال بانه اكد لنظيره
الايراني رغبه المملكه في تعزيز الثقه
المتبادله مع ايران وتوسيع نطاق التعاون
معها لاسيما في المجال الامني ما هو
المقصود بالمجال الامني الى اي افق يمكن
ان يصل هذا التعاون في المجال الامني
نعم اي مراقب يقرا الاتفاقيه او التصريح
ممكن يقراها قراءه صحيحه او يقراها على
هواه لكن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه عندما
قال اليوم تعزيز الثقه المتبادله
الثقه المتبادله تعني اشياء كثيره بين
المملكه هو ايران وايضا تعزيز الاستقرار
الاقليمي الاستقرار الاقليمي يعني الامن
في البحرين وفي اليمن وفي الكويت وفي مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وايضا يشمل العراق هذا
الاستقرار الاقليمي طبعا يعني استئناف
البعثات الدبلوماسيه استدلبها الوزير
الخارجيه السعودي على تقدم وتطور العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه
ويعني كانت
يعني اشاره لان المملكه وايران ماضيتان في
تطبيق الاتفاقيه السعوديه الايرانيه بما
فيها الذي ينفيه ضيفك العزيز وهو اعتقد
ليست السعوديه اي مصلحه في مصلحه في اعاده
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه مجرد علاقات
دبلوماسيه دون ان تلتزم ايران بما تم
الاتفاق عليه في بكين مساله
الاتفاقات السعوديه الايرانيه واضحه بعضها
مصرح به وبعضها زي ما تفضل الاخ مهدي انها
عدم التدخل في الدول في الدول العربيه وهو
يعني
شرط واضح بعدم التد الدول العربيه معناته
شرط تلتزم
الدوله ايران الشقيقه وهذا لا يحتاج تفسير
الامني ولا من السيد مهدي هذا شيء واضح
اما مساله عدم تدخل
الكلمه المطاطيه في الشؤون الخارجيه للدول
الداخليه للدول الاخرى هذا ايضا مبدا
سياسي معروف لكن الاتفاقيه منصت على عدم
التدخل في الدول العربيه حرفيا
وتعني الدول العربيه ما تعنيه والايرانيون
ايضا متفقون على ان هذه التدخلات قد اضرت
في ايران اكثر مما فادتهم لذلك سعه
الايران الدوله الى الحصول على علاقات
مميزه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه والبحث
في المجال التعاون الاقتصادي بين الدولتين
سواء كان على مستوى البترول او على مستوى
القضايا الامنيه والاستراتيجيه او على
مستوى مساله تحيد مجلس الخليج العربي من
القوى العالميه عندما يكون هناك اتفاق
سعودي ايراني اعتقد هناك يعني داعي لاي
اسطول اجنبي ان يحضر الى الخليج العربي
ايضا هناك يعني اتفاق ضروري للسعوديه مع
ايران اللي هو الاتفاق البترولي اذا لم
يكن هناك يعني اتفاق سعودي ايراني وتنسيق
على اعلى مستوى اعتقد في اسعار البترول
اوبك لن يكون هناك نجاح
لدول أبق في مساله التقرير اسعار البترول
المستقبلا لذلك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تعي الدور الايراني الكبير في انتاج النفط
وايضا مساله الاستثمار المستقبلي في الغاز
والبترول وجميع
النشاطات التجاريه الاخرى المملكه لديها
مع ايران اكثر من 20 اتفاقيه امنيه
واقتصاديه تركز المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالدرجه الاولى على على الاتفاقيات
الامنيه من ضمنها التسليم
القاعده ومنسوبي القاعده الذين يتواجدون
على الاراضي الايرانيه وهذا يعني يعني سبب
رئيسي وجدي لاخت الاخوه الايرانيين في
مساله تطبيق الاتفاقيه ونحن نعرف ان افراد
القاعده مازال كثير منهم متواجد في ايران
والايرانيين احيانا يلمحون لذلك ايضا هناك
اتفاقيات اقتصاديه لا اعتقد ان السعوديه
في غنى عنها ولكنها بالدرجه الاولى في
حاجه لتطبيق الاتفاقيات الامنيه وتسليم ما
لدى ايران من مواطنين سعوديين مخليين
بالامن وكذلك يعني التعاون والتنسيق
وتعزيز الثقه في مساله التعاون
الاستخباراتي بين الدولتين واحترام كل
منهما للاخرى وعدم يعني اغلاق الامن
الداخلي في الدول الاخرى او في دول مجلس
التعاون الخليج طيب ملفات كثيره اسمع من
السيد محمد مهدي سيد محمد مهدي ذكرت بان
هذا التقارب سينعكس ايجابا على ملفات
اقليميه ما هي هذه الملفات وكيف
عفوا بس اسمحي لي اولا ان ارد فقط على
نقطتين يعني انا استغرب حقيقه من بعض ما
يقوله الضيف الكريم وهو يعني لا يعني
لست ادري ماذا اقول يعني
هل يصدق احد في العالم ان المفاوضه
الايراني
بعقليته وبحنكته وبطول نفسه ان ياتي ويوقع
على نص يقول او ينص على ان ايران ان لا
تتدخل في شؤون الدول العربيه انا لا اتصور
يعني ان احدا يصدق ذلك هذه لست ادري من
اين جاء بها
ضيفك الكريم او بالنسبه
للاتفاقيه الامنيه الموقعه بين البلدين
والذي ادعى الضيف الكريم انها تنص على
تسليم عناصر داعش اول
تنظيم داعش يعني معروف من اسسه ومن دعمه
ومن
ارفده بالكثير من العناصر لا اريد ان
اتطرق الى ذلك لكن هذه الاتفاقيه الامنيه
مطلقا لم تتطرق الى موضوع اصلا ايران ترفض
وجود عناصر داعش على اراضيها ولا يمكن
ايضا ان توقع على نص يعني ورد فيه ما لا
حقيقه له وما لا تقبل به ايران لذلك يعني
النصوص التصريحات التقارير الاخبار كلها
موجوده
ومتوفره لدى القارئ الكريم تصريحات خارجيه
سعودي اليوم كانت واضحه نعم ماذا عن سؤالي
ما هي الملفات اذا التي ستنعكس عليها هذه
او هذا التقارب سينعكس عليها ايجابا
يعني اذا ايران والسعوديه دولتان كبيرتان
في المنطقه وانا اتصور ان كلاهما يتحمل
مسؤوليه دعم القضايا العادله ودعم شعوب
المنطقه في قضيه فلسطين في القضايا الاخرى
في المنطقه في مكافحه الارهاب لابد ان
تحظى شعوب المنطقه بدعم كلا الدولتين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه اذا كانت الاراده
السياسيه لدى البلدين متوفره وهي كذلك وان
لم تتدخل ايرادات سياسيه اجنبيه اخرى على
الخط من دون شك يمكن ان تؤثر على محمد
الحسن بين البلدين
نعم من تقصدون
بتدخلات اجنبيه
اي اي اراده سياسيه تاتي من الخارج ان كان
ذلك في امن منطقه الخليج الفارسي تواجد
القوات الاجنبيه في هذه المنطقه التاثير
من قبل الاداره الامريكيه التوقعات
بالنسبه للانتخابات القادمه في الولايات
المتحده ربما تاثيرات اقليميه الضغوط التي
تورد على بعض الدول لتطبيع العلاقات مع
الكيان الصهيوني ولحسن الحظ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ما زالت ترفض ذلك الكثير
من المؤثرات
الخارجيه يمكن ان
لا سمح الله على هذه الاراده السياسيه
للدولتين ربما تخل في هذه العلاقات وانا
لا اتصور ذلك لانني ارى ان الدولتين لهما
الاراده السياسيه القاطعه في حلحله
المشاكل بين يعني
التاثيرات الخارجيه حدود هذه التاثيرات
على التقارب السعودي الايراني
نعم ليس هناك بالنسبه للتاثيرات الخارجيه
كما تدعي بعد الصحف لكن اسمحي لي في اقل
من فتره في كلمتين داعش اسستها الدول التي
استفادت من وجودها في العراق اللي هي ثلاث
دول ايران تركيا الولايات المتحده وهذا
الكلام ليس من لدني هذا الكلام من عام 91
وهو يعني ثابت الدراسات انه هناك دوله
ستقام
للمتطرفين الاسلاميين في شمال العراق
استغلت ايران وتركيا والولايات المتحده
هذا الموضوع
يعني المعلومه وتصحيح معلومه السيد ولا
داعش هي هجمت في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولست السعوديه
بالعلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هل يمكن ان يكون لها اي انعكاسات في تاخير
او يعني تعجيل هذا التقارب بين السعوديه
وايران
عزيزتي المملكه العربيه السعوديه تسعى عن
مصالحها سواء مصالحها الامنيه او
الاقتصاديه لذلك سعت الى توقيع هذا
الاتفاق مع ايران بالضمانات الصينيه حتى
يعني تضمن
امن بلادها وامن المنطقه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط باكملها لذلك اعتقد ان ليس لولا
لولا الولايات المتحده اي تاثير على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ليس من صالح
الولايات المتحده ان تتوقع السعوديه هذا
الاتفاق مع الايرانيين لذلك اعتقد
السعوديه خارجه عن اي ضغوط سواء امريكيه
اوروبيه او اي من اي كان مصلحه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي بالدرجه الاولى في
توقيع هذه الاتفاقيات وايضا نعود للاخ
مهدي اقول له اقرا الاتفاقيه ستجد نصا
وحرفا ان
للاسف انتهى الوقت سعد بن عمر مدير مركز
القرن العربي
للدراسات شكرا لك وشكرا للسيد محمد مهدي
شريعه مداري البحث المتخصص في الدراسات
السياسيه الاقليميه من طهران الى هنا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]